okay so the next story I have is Elon
Musk so Elon Musk is quite the guy he
bought Twitter because he is motivated
to have a truly free speech Network so
as someone that has been demonetized on
YouTube or this hateful speech this is
something that I'm very passionate about
I really hope that Twitter can compete
with YouTube someday because it is very
frustrating as a content creator to be
constantly having to censor myself with
vague guidelines that don't tell us what
we did wrong so essentially YouTube can
just come in and say every day oh that's
hate speech that's hate speech that's
hate speech just because they feel like
it